[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es mal wieder eine torte die
ihr euch gewünscht habt und zwar eine
eilig hört orte haben wirklich ganz ganz
viele zuschauer danach gefragt ich
wollte aber zuerst einmal ein basic
rezept für euch machen wie man eierlikör
alkoholfrei selber machen kann gut im
prinzip ist es halt eher wie eine
vanillesoße aus der flasche die man aber
wirklich selber sehr gut zubereiten kann
das ganze alkoholfrei und so kann auch
jemand der keinen alkohol verzerrt diese
torte zubereiten und essen
ich habe sie jetzt zubereitet und das
ist wirklich eine torte die super
einfach und ganz ganz schnell
hergestellt ist und da könnt ihr euch
wirklich sonntagmittags auch noch
hinstellen und backen und am nachmittag
schon freunde erwarten zu kaffee und
kuchen und diese torte darf später der
murat probieren und ich zeige euch jetzt
erst einmal die zutaten für den rührteig
der ist nämlich super einfach für den
teig verwende ich fünf eier eine prise
salz 100 gramm zucker etwas vanille
extrakt 200 gramm gemahlene mandeln
einen teelöffel backpulver jeweils 100
gramm mehl schokostreusel eierlikör und
öl
ich nehme jetzt zuerst die eier die
kommen hier in die rührschüssel dann
zucker und salz dazu natürlich etwas
vanille extrakt wobei ich es selbst
gemachte liköre letzteren habe und jetzt
die masse für etwa fünf minuten richtig
cremig verrühren
jetzt kommen die beiden flüssigkeiten
dazu dafür stelle ich die küchenmaschine
immer ein bisschen runter und dann
vorsichtig einrühren
[Musik]
jetzt kommen noch die übrigen zutaten
rein also die trockenen einmal die
mandeln die habe ich bereits selbst
gemahlen mehl und backpulver kann man
ein bisschen vermischen und dann auch
die schokostreusel
jetzt vorsichtig mit dem schneebesen
unterheben
[Musik]
das hat jetzt ja auch keine back festen
schokostreusel sondern die ganz normalen
und ist auch ganz schön wenn die da so
ein bisschen schmelzen im backofen und
dem teig dann wird das schöne
schokoladig und den teig völlig jetzt in
meinen filmen habe ich bereits auf 24 cm
eingestellt und schlagt ihn vorher mit
backpapier ein damit der teig nicht
ausläuft
bei dem teig wird auch theoretisch gehen
ohne backpapier einschlagen also einfach
mit einer dauer back folie darunter weil
es nicht so sehr flüssig ist aber wenn
ihr sicher gehen wollte das wirklich
nichts ausläuft wenn der teig zu flüssig
ist dann schlagt genommen westen immer
mit backpapier
[Musik]
und so kann er schon in den backofen
den tortenboden habe ich nach dem backen
aus der form herausgelöst und dann auf
ein abkühlt etr gestürzt und jetzt
komplett abkühlen lassen
jetzt gebe ich hier in torten retter
drauf dann kann es einmal umdrehen hat
es ein schönes muster auf der oberfläche
mit streiks den tortenboden einmal
waagerecht durch
und ihr könnt jetzt entscheiden ob wir
den tortenboden gerne führen möchte mit
marmelade zum beispiel oder ihn einfach
mit bisschen eierlikör oder einer
anderen marmelade bestreicht sag ich mal
die zutaten für die füllung verwende ich
aprikosenmarmelade dies ohne stückchen
und feind passiert für die creme 500
gramm sahne etwas seiner partei einen
teelöffel vanille extrakt den selbst
gemachten eierlikör und für die deko
noch schokoladen raspeln oder blättchen
ich nehme hier die aprikosenmarmelade
zum film die ist nämlich schön fruchtig
und passt auch wirklich sehr sehr gut
dazu
[Musik]
er kommt direkt der torten deckel drauf
wird stelle ich die torte noch mal ganz
kurz in den kühlschrank und kann dann
gleich die sahne steif schlagen
visana fühle jetzt in einen großen topf
in der große rührschüssel com bisschen
vanille extrakt hat so und jetzt wird
die sache kurz berührt und währenddessen
kommt an seiner partnerin und bei seiner
tat könnt ihr euch einfach merken pro
100 gramm masse kommt ein teelöffel
seiner passion und die torte sind echt
super einfach wenn ihr sie gerne flach
haben möchte
nehmen wir die hälfte an den teig
zutaten dann könnt ihr nämlich ohne
durchschneiden einfach die sahne creme
direkt auf den tortenboden machen
und welche sagt sarah alleine ist nicht
so langweilig da kann natürlich auch
quark noch zufügen oder schmand oder
frischkäse alles was wir gerne haben
[Musik]
kann ich die torte mit der sahne
einstreichen aber ich habe etwa ein
drittel auf für die sahne trug noch was
schön die oberfläche und den rand das
geht immer am besten mit einer winkel
palette
[Musik]
ich schaue hier immer dass ich einmal
die torte komplett einstreiche dann
glätte ich die oberfläche und dann den
rand
[Musik]
und dann die oberfläche einfach noch so
nach innen streichen
jetzt fühle ich die torte ganz kurz und
fülle die restliche creme schon mal in
einen spritzbeutel mit einer großen
stand hülle
jetzt setzt sich erstmal die torte auf
die platte um
[Musik]
an den rand der torte kommen jetzt diese
schokostreusel und die könnt ihr
entweder mit der hand so an drücken oder
ihr nehmt einfach eine zeitkarte dann
legte sie hier so drauf und weil die ja
flexibel ist können dass es ein bisschen
dran drücken
macht am besten bei euch vorne ich habe
jetzt die rückseite nicht gesehen aber
aus versehen in die saane gedrückt aber
ich dachte dann seht ihr es halt besser
egal ist schlimm dass verdecken wir
einfach mit noch mehr schokostreusel
hallo mama meine mama steht am fenster
weg
[Musik]
könnte ja einfach mal meine eltern
probieren lassen ich habe das immer so
kamerascheu
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich die torte wieder auf der
dreh platte gesetz so kann ich nicht so
ein bisschen einfacher arbeiten und
keine ziele ringsherum die tupfen auf
spritzen
wichtig ist dass die tupfen direkt
aneinander gespritzt werden damit in die
mitte dann eilig gegossen werden kann
[Applaus]
also bloß keine lücken lassen so
unternehme ich jetzt wieder den
selbstgemachten alkoholfreien eiliger da
wird es einfach in die mitte gegossen
[Applaus]
und da ist ein bisschen drehen und
verteilt das nicht ganz gut
ganz klassische oma torte ständig sitzt
vom äußerlichen herr nicht die
spektakulärste torte aber bestimmt eine
der leckerste ich stelle sie jetzt für
zwei stunden in den kühlschrank und
danken wir schon probieren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt ist die torte gut durchgeführt und
murat und geräte sind schon da zu
integrieren dem toben bei der mama
paneele an die wand gemacht kommt jetzt
problem denn kleine teller und in großer
teller hielt man einen seriösen beitrag
also nicht jetzt gerade beim glatten
legen da oben unseriös arbeitende
heiligkeit worte alkoholfrei das merkt
wir eh nicht die haut und wir anderen ja
wir suchen wir mal dran denn da also
drin wenn der fluss gegangen ist aber
daher mit naja man bei daimler die kurse
seien die zu essen schöne gegangen ich
lege schon wieder meine kuchen teil ist
oft fünf minuten und murat und
gummiteilen zehn minuten hören so es war
schon schaukeln kantonalpartei
konsistent kuchen sahne marmelade mit
super bis jetzt bestimmt an glücklich
sagen oder weil hier setzt das tier hält
an
damit ist super high konsens klasse ich
möchte nicht noch einer da hatte ich ja
woher weiß ich nicht
[Gelächter]
da habe ich ihm auch machen mir die
kamera aus ist augen gestorben mit der
gabel
okay man wenn ihr wollt dass ich nur
raten die öfter zu probieren dazu hole
dann schreibt in die kommentare
wenn über ihr tun
manchmal macht das rollo ich bin ein
hersteller kündigt backen ich denke mal
protokoll dass irgendetwas wird es
nachmachen
ja ja selbst probieren ja okay okay das
kann der könig kann auch wenn diese
beleidigt mich darin schatz
doch lieber die kamera aus also danke
schön also danke schön was zu verwickeln
also falls ihr auch diese torte nach
machen wollt dann geht auch schief -
blog.de das gibt noch mal ganz genau
und falls ihr den beiden weiter zu
gucken wollte dass ich jetzt einfach die
küche mit daumen zu schlechten mich von
ihr erstellten und vom genießt luft raus
weil ihr ja den spruch was die schwaben
fressen fressen die hessen ja ja ich bin
ich nämlich hesse
er sagt dann auch immer die heißeste
nichts erbarme dich die hesse komme ja
er war mir zu spät die hesse komme was
ist ein liegt nein das war es war im
amerikanischen bürgerkrieg waren auch
hessischer regiment
und du weißt mittag haben haben die
amerikaner damit richtig jetzt kommt
haben die amerikaner gerufen waren wir
wissen durchgegangen wie ein heißes
messer durch warme butter erbarme dich
die hesse kommt so gehört sich das auch
wenn es die amerikaner sagen wie hört
sich das andere auf englisch nummer so
und sagt doch du weißt nicht mehr
aber hauptsache ein scheiß rausquetschen
ich mache mir jetzt aber bis dahin
tschüss macht mir hör auf jetzt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
an
einfach so der wein ist reif
normalerweise mag ich ja gerne süße
sachen aber zum wein passt doch was
schönes herzhaftes sally zaubert neue
kreationen für ein weinfest
beim herz auf gut backen kann man viel
mehr improvisieren zwiebelkuchen gemüse
tat und cash traditionelles einfach mal
anders unser gespannt ob es gut ankommt
einfach sally sonntag 16 uhr